so
today we are very happy to have three
speaker
and the first one will be elias
you've been at university of toronto
right yes that's right
yeah and um you know what let me just
not take out of your time with
saying stuff that i don't know and just
let your
work and beautiful slides speak for
themselves
all right awesome
[Music]
okay uh well thanks everybody for uh for
coming
to this session and uh and entertaining
uh my talk
uh i'm elias i'm a new professor at the
university of toronto in industrial
engineering
um and today i'm going to present uh
some recent uh joint works
with uh colleagues uh antonia schmele at
zeus institute in berlin
ambrosh gleissner and sebastian pocuta
uh
and andrea lodi at polytechnic morial
and the stock is really
uh at the core of the theme of the
session
uh ml for solvers so really going to go
into solvers in this case it's going to
be
mixed integer programming solvers
um and so uh i am kind of it's mandatory
for me
to start by saying that you know given
that this is a
semester or workshop on various solving
technologies for um constraints uh to
say that you know mixed integer
programming is probably the most
widely useful of these so here i'm
mentioning just a few
um kind of high impact uh applications
that
that we've seen over the last few
decades this has been going on
uh for uh for many decades uh actually
and so
you know while uh there's indeed very
wide applicability of mip
uh because of that uh we are also
uh kind of always pushing to try to
improve solvers and algorithms
and scale them up to harder problems and
larger instances etc so this talk is
kind of um
in that direction so integer programming
in one slide um
so we're going to look at the branch and
bound uh we're going to work within the
branch and bound algorithm
um specifically the linear programming
based branch and bound algorithm
the kind of problem we're interested in
is this simple one
we're trying to minimize a linear
function in the variables x
subject to a bunch of linear constraints
and the variables are in this case
binary but you could have
general integer variables or a mix of
integer and continuous variables
so the branch and bound algorithm is a
three search algorithm which perceives
as follows
um it starts uh with an initial node
which represents
um just a linear relaxation of the
original
integer problem um we solved that
and because we're minimizing we obtain
an optimistic
lower bound on the optimal value of the
problem
um if that solution happens to be for
the integer we're done we found an
optimal solution
in many cases that will not be the case
um
and so we'll have to do a bunch of
additional work
to get there in particular if we have an
existing best solution
uh we will prune a node in the search
tree
if its lower bound is worse than the
integer solution
uh so that's kind of the rule for
pruning and this is where
the bound from branch and bound comes um
we might also try to add
cuts to tighten the formulation so
extend this a
matrix and b vector with additional rows
to kind of tighten the feasible region
the other thing which we're going to be
interested in in this talk
is to run a bunch of heuristics we're
going to refer to as primal heuristics
primal
because they focus on feasibility and
finding good solutions
so you might have a pool of solution of
different heuristics
uh and you'll run them to try to find an
improved
feasible solution what we'll call an an
incumbent uh if you do find such a
solution then you update
your best solution or your upper bound
and then last
um and perhaps most importantly we'll
need to branch
in order to be able to explore the space
of possible integer solutions
uh we do that by selecting some uh
integer variable
um and updating its lower and upper
bounds
in this case for the binary case we'll
just fix it to either zero or one
um so for example say we pick x2
um and then we'll go back to one we'll
select
one of the two open nodes or nodes on
the frontier in this case n1 and n2
and we'll keep repeating these kind of
six steps
until we found an optimal solution
and we have no more nodes on the
frontier so then you have a globally
optimal solution
certifiably so okay
so the way solvers typically behave um
is something like this so the horizontal
axis here
is the search three nodes that we're
exploring over time
so the search flows left to right
in particular i'm highlighting the
optimal value
this is the the vertical axis so that's
the objective value
over time and there's typically two
quantities you look at
the first one is the primal bound
remember here we're minimizing so we
want to
go low and hit that opt uh
line uh so that's what we're going to
call the primal bound which is the value
of the best solution
so far in the search the other quantity
that also evolves
during the search is the dual bound
which
is simply the most optimistic relaxation
value
among the nodes on the frontier the
nodes we have not explored yet
in the branch and boundary okay and this
gives you a dual bound
and at any point in time you can check
primal versus dual
and you obtain what we call the
optimality gap right so
this is a feature of this kind of
complete or exact algorithm
um is that as soon as you have an
integer solution
you get a guarantee on its quality
uh and as the search evolves given you
know sufficient time
you're gonna converge to gap 0 finding
the optimal solution
and proving that it is so
okay heuristics
in this context the step i showed in the
algorithm matter quite a bit
if you have a better primal bound then
um you can use that to prune off
more nodes in the frontier of the tree
and so you close this gap
in green faster which is quite which is
quite nice
uh the other desirable kind of or
consequence of
having good heuristics is that if you
have better feasible solutions early
um whoever's making decisions based on
these solutions can act
more quickly and so there are many cases
where uh you might have integer programs
that take many hours or even days
but you need to commit you know your
supply chain um
decision or your transportation network
decision uh in a shorter amount of time
so having a
very high quality solution very early on
becomes
extremely useful so one way
that uh the integer programming
community quantifies
this progress on the primal side uh is
through what's called the primal
integral
um and so this is uh a plot that's kind
of similar to the top half of the one i
showed earlier
what you're seeing on the horizontal
axis is the primal gap which you can
think of as
relative quality of the objective value
to the optimal
so zero is optimum you want to be at the
at the very bottom
and you start with something arbitrarily
bad let's give it a value of one
and as the this three search finds more
solutions
it drops in this kind of staircase um
pattern and the primal integral
essentially measures this area under the
curve
this thing that we have in light blue
and that's called the primal integral
and you can kind of compute it
you can't compute it on the fly you
compute it in an evaluation phase after
the solver has terminated
with knowledge of the optimal value of
the problem
and it's going to drop any time you find
a new improved integer solution or
incumbent
so this is a metric that we're going to
use down the line
now to motivate further the need
for very good heuristics or for finding
very good feasible solutions early
i'd like to say that there's a kind of a
common experience in many real problems
that
exact solvers will often find the
optimal solution
very early in the search and then spend
uh the large majority of the time trying
to prove optimality
okay so this is not the kind of problem
that i'm interested in in this
presentation so i'm going to talk about
other classes of problems which also
naturally occur where
finding high quality solutions is not
easy
right and so that's going to take time
and we want to kind of reduce that time
one such problem is the generalized
independent set problem
um it's quite nice generalization of the
classical
maximal independent set you have a graph
and you want to select a subset of
vertices to maximize some notion of
revenue so each vertex has some weight
this is same as typical independent set
the additional thing is that you can
pick
adjacent nodes or vertices
uh at a cost which is typically you
cannot do in
in the standard maximum independent set
um and so each edge has a cost cij it
might be infinity meaning you cannot
pick a particular pair of connected
nodes or vertices
and each node has a revenue ri and what
you want to maximize is typical
sum of revenues minus the sum
of the costs uh that you that you pay
for
ignoring independence along an edge um
so quite classical uh simple model but
turns out
it's pretty hard to solve even for uh
graphs with
you know few hundred nodes or vertices
and
a few thousand edges um this problem
turns out to be
difficult even for commercial uh mip
solvers and there are
you know some dedicated techniques that
can improve on that but
in this talk we're to focus kind of on
general mixed integer linear
uh programming formulations um
so jsp is uh uh just the abbreviation
for
generalized independent set problem uh
it's it's quite challenging as a problem
so here what i'm showing is again this
primal gap
so normalizing the value of the best
solution seen during branch and mount
uh to the optimum so optimal is zero um
and you can see here times on unlock
scale and second
and even after four hours this is the
time limit we set for the for the skip
solver in this case
and the optimal solution is not found um
and you know it takes
tens of minutes in some cases to get to
within you know 0.1 within 10 percent
uh of optimum so this is what i mean
when i say
quite challenging um you see the area
under the blue curve which is the
default skip solver
is quite large in a sense um
and so this is not a case of a problem
where the optimal solution is found very
early in the search
um and so these results i just showed uh
are with the non-commercial
integer programming solver skip um it's
one of the faster ones
if in case you're not familiar um it's
kind of the only one that's
you know within an order of magnitude on
common benchmarks
from the commercial solvers you might
know like cplex or gorobi
um a few hundred thousand lines of code
quite advanced
lots of features and ways to extend it
um and recently
uh some colleagues have also uh been
making an effort towards
facilitating machine learning within
that complicated
solver we won't use this specific code
base but i just
wanted to note it um as a
kind of interesting avenue if you're
interested in this domain uh
so everything i'm going to show you is
within the context of skip
but lots of these ideas are quite
general we just needed a solver that we
could instrument
uh fully um so skip is is quite involved
um here i'm showing you a snapshot of
kind of the different components of the
solver
what we're interested in is this kind of
bouquet on the right
called primal heuristic these are you
know all the heuristics that are
implemented
in skip so you don't need to count
there's probably
30 or 40 in there actually in the
implementation
the most recent version of skip there's
57
primal heuristics so these are things
ranging from
simple rounding of fractional variables
make them integer try to see if you get
a feasible solution with a good value
all the way to large neighborhood search
and solving
other integer programs that might get
you
an improved solution so quite an arsenal
of possible algorithms
and it's interesting to kind of think
about
how to manage all these heuristics in a
sense there's a trade-off you can
design 100 heuristics but then if you
keep running them
then you're going to spend time doing
that that might take away from
the overall progress of the search um
so this is kind of what we're going to
try to help skip do
using a certain machine learning
formulation uh to give you a sense of
these heuristics one common class
uh there's about 15 uh different
heuristics in skip
from this family uh it's known as diving
heuristics
uh it's a very simple depth first search
type of approach
so let's say you're in branch and bound
you're at the screen node
um what diving heuristics do is they fix
a sequence of variables
here x5 x7 x9 and they try to check
if you get lucky and through this fixing
you find a good integer solution great
and otherwise you run for a number of
you know diving iterations some maximum
diving depth
and you know you abort if you're not
lucky if you haven't found an integer
solution
the variance of this algorithm comes
from defining different rules
for selecting the next variable so you
might want to round
the least fractional variable or maybe
you want to
round or fix variables in dense
constraints we need constraints which
have
many variables with non-zero
coefficients uh so there's a whole bunch
of these
each one of them gives you a different
heuristic each heuristic performs
differently depending on the instances
that
that that you look at so this is an
example of one class of heuristic
which we're going to try to control
to manage heuristics a skip has a bunch
of parameters
for example it might say that this
heuristic nlp diving
should run at frequency 10 meaning it
should run every other 10 nodes
right this is to avoid the case where it
runs at every node wastes time
but is ultimately ineffective so time is
precious here
and you could have a bunch of these
parameters for each kind of heuristic
but more importantly the way skip
or most integer programming solvers
manage heuristics
is through a heuristic loop that works
like this you have a pool of heuristics
you have pre-assigned priorities amongst
them from higher
right highest priority to lowest
priority what you're going to do you're
going to iterate over the heuristics
each one of them has a max iterations a
limit
for how long it can run um you perform
one more step
and if the heuristic finds a new
incumbent a solution that's integer and
better than all we've seen before
then you exit this loop you don't
continue to the other heuristics
this is to emphasize that if you have a
good ordering of the heuristics meaning
you have a very successful heuristic
placed at the first position and it
consistently finds integer solutions
then the solver will not waste time
running the other less useful heuristics
so this would be very important um for
for what i'm gonna propose here
now at this point i've kind of
introduced this notion of parameters of
the
of the solver uh so it's natural to
wonder you know why
why not use parameter tuning so this is
you know one parameter tuning or
algorithm configuration approach
from from a while back from hutteritol
where it was it was used to tune c plex
at the time on a bunch of mixed integer
programming
uh benchmark sets and the way these
algorithms work
is through testing parameter
configurations trying to model the
function
from these parameter settings to
whatever
performance metric you care about say
running time and then trying to
kind of navigate that function uh
intelligently to find good points in the
configuration space
and again this has been used
successfully but for the setting we're
interested in here which is
managing heuristics for very complicated
problems
problems with very long
time limits this black box parameter
tuning approach
is not necessarily the best one it can
be slow
and every time you want to evaluate one
parameter configuration
that might take multiple hours so for
this generalized independent set
it's about four hours the other issue is
black box optimization just uh assumes
that
the solver is a black box and so it
cannot exploit any
knowledge about how changing a parameter
is affecting the internals of the solver
so these are some issues that we're
going to
address the first thing as i said
that we note is that the ordering of the
heuristic how you prioritize them in the
solver
matters a lot so what you're seeing here
is
a bunch of heuristics on two types of
problems this independent set
in blue and another network flow problem
also very complicated
um and you'll see that on the
vertical axis we have the solution
success rate meaning the fraction of
nodes in the tree
at which running a heuristic leads to a
solution
so between zero and one higher is better
and you'll see that the ordering is very
different
for the two types of problem so we're
sorting from largest to smallest
with respect to blue here and you'll see
that the golden bars from the other set
of problems
have very different ordering meaning
different heuristics are successful for
different
types of problems which means that one
set of parameters
at the top independent of your of that
of the instance type
is probably not going to be very useful
and so first insight is ordering matters
just empirically the other thing that
matters
is the number of iterations the max
iterations
for which you run a heuristic so here
we're showing three different heuristics
as you increase their iteration limit
and what you're seeing on the vertical
axis
is the fraction of runs for which the
heuristic
finds a feasible solution and so you'll
see they have very different patterns
uh you know the green one can find
zero point you know eighty percent of
its solution
at roughly 50 iterations whereas the
others
need three five times more iterations
the other thing you notice is there's
diminishing returns right meaning
uh increasing the iteration limit is not
necessarily gonna
give you lots more solutions um
and so this is a pattern that any kind
of learning approach
should be able to leverage automatically
based on
uh you know data set that captures that
information and so
the number of iterations also matters
and so putting it all together um here's
kind of the
framework i'm working within number one
you have a mixed integer program that's
challenging on the primal side
meaning it's not easy to find very good
solutions number two
as typical in the machine learning
setting you have a distribution over
instances
so you have a bunch of instances from
the same problem that you'd like to kind
of
fit something to condition three
uh the solver takes a long time uh so
this is kind of related to one
uh the the problem is not something that
you can solve in a few seconds if it
solves in a few seconds or minutes
you're better off using algorithm
configuration and
four you're too lazy to design your own
custom heuristic you don't want to study
the math of generalized independent set
and do polyhedral theory
um and so the way you're approaching
things maybe you're an industry
uh or you just wanna solve a problem uh
you don't wanna write a paper designing
a new algorithm for it you just wanna
solve it
uh and so you see a solver like skip as
a hammer
and your instances as a nail so what i'm
going to talk about
next is how do you refine the hammer for
your kind of nail
when it comes to primal heuristics
[Music]
the kind of data as i've hinted to
before
that we're going to try to collect and
exploit
looks something like this you have a
branch about three
and then i'm taking a sample of three
nodes here you see the arrow from the
node to its corresponding name and one
and two and three
um and these bars um correspond
uh to different heuristics so each uh
each color represents a heuristic h1 h2
h3
and the vertical axis is the number of
iterations
for which they ran on a given node
and whether they succeeded or they
failed so if they hit this infinity sign
it means
we ran them for whatever limit they had
and they didn't
succeed in finding a solution if they
terminate before the infinity sign
it means they terminated in that much
time and found the solution
um and so the green bar the last green
bar here means
you know a solution was found by
heuristic h3 in two iterations
uh so this is data called heuristic
performance data that one can collect
by simply taking the training instances
running the solver
executing the heuristics and keeping
track of these
bars essentially um so this is how we're
going to set up
the problem of managing these heuristics
so let's say we do that
um one thing you might ask for um
is the following we would like to
sequence
these three heuristics and assign to
each of them an iteration limit
such that we minimize the overall
average number of iterations
needed to find a solution so to to
continue with this uh toy example here
uh if you run heuristic h1 in orange
for one iteration what you're going to
get is you're going to
solve n1 node n1 you're going to find a
solution for that based on this
historical data
then if following that uh so
and also h1 is going to fail on the
other two instances you see it goes to
infinity here so it's not going to find
any solutions
now after you run heuristic one for one
iteration if you run
heuristic 2 in blue for three iterations
then you can see
that n2 and n3 will be solved because
that's what the data
said and so this would be for example an
optimal schedule
because you run it for a very short
amount of time four iterations in total
and you solve all three instances
meaning you find solutions
for all three of them so this is
something we can do retrospectively
if we have the right data set like these
bars
and so this will be the scheduling
problem this is why i have learning to
schedule
in the title of the talk because we're
going to try to collect the data
that lets us run such a solve such a
scheduling problem
that i have at the top of the slide and
uh obtain a a
an optimal schedule or or a very good uh
schedule
so short schedule solves many of the
instances in the training set
where each instance is not a mip
instance necessarily it's rather a
node within a search tree for a given
nip instance
and so the overall framework looks
something like this in the first step
you run your mip solver on a bunch of
training instances
each of these threes corresponds to one
say independent set instance
the colors are just to signify these are
different instances from the same
problem
step two uh you know within that run you
execute heuristics very aggressively
and you collect performance data like
the one i showed in the previous slide
and then in step three you just match
them all up together so every node
you've seen
in any of these threes becomes a data
point so to speak
within each data point you know how long
each heuristic took
and whether it found a solution or not
and then you solve a scheduling problem
which gives you kind of the best way to
sequence
heuristics so that you find as many
solutions as possible
in a minimal amount of iterations so
this is the kind of the overall
framework without going into too much
details there's
multiple uh kind of benefits uh to
to what we're proposing here in terms of
implementation is not so difficult to do
we did some minor hacking in skip uh
that's that's really
not so complicated the other point is
you need one solver run per instance
so compared to typical like very
expensive machine learning approaches a
reinforcement learning where you need to
see every every instance many times to
train your model
we don't have that so we do one solve
per instance and due to that
there's massive parallelization
potential here because every instance is
independent of the other so even if you
have many instances if you have as many
cpu cores you could just run as many
copies of skip
and get all this data so it paralyzes uh
kind of embarrassingly
and last although the scheduling problem
that i've hinted at is np hard it
generalizes some known
uh set covering variants uh a greedy
heuristic that we've implemented works
very well
and it's kind of based on previous work
but but different
and so this gives a very nice framework
for collecting data
and obtaining or training a schedule
that performs well
retrospectively on the set of data that
we've observed
now what do you do at test time uh you
have a schedule which is derived from
the training data it's this
set of colored bars
do you see the ordering uh one two three
four et cetera
so first heuristics are the more
important ones they're the one more
likely to find good solutions
quickly and the the length of the bar is
the number of iterations we're going to
give it so how much
time we're going to give it so you see
the first one here in in gold
uh doesn't take too much time but it's
good historically
whereas others like four require quite a
bit
uh more iterations now once you have
that schedule from the training data
you can simply tell skip to use that by
setting
the priority of each heuristic and the
maximum iterations
and now you have your test instance
which we have not seen in data
collection and training
and you just run skip on that following
the the heuristic schedule that was
derived from the training data
so this is a one size fits all schedule
it's similar to
the typical parameter configuration
setting uh where you kind of
find a one solution that works well on a
distribution of instances
and it's also similar to a recent
framework for learning and algorithms
proposed by
nina balkan and co-authors in 2019 so
it's kind of a
pretty standard one but it's not an
instance specific approach so
that's one way that uh what we're
proposing could potentially be extended
or
or improved um so going back uh and to
kind of show some results of how this
works
um will generate instances following
some standard practices
from the generalized independent set
problem which is again quite notorious
uh to find good solutions for and i'm
going to present
a bunch of results on that
so first thing to observe is if we look
at this primal integral how the best
solution evolves over time
in gold here we have the learned
schedule and in blue we have the default
setting of the skip solver
which many humans kind of engineered
over time this is not a trivial
uh setting in by any means
and so you want to be closer to the
bottom left corner it means your
integral your area under the curve is
smaller
meaning you find very good solutions
very early
and you'll see that our method in gold
here
gets a solution that's kind of within 10
of optimum
within one minute whereas blue you know
needs
10 times more time so it takes multiple
minutes
and so this is the kind of behavior that
that we get to observe in practice
um if we kind of aggregate that on many
instances
i'm not going to go through the detail
of the experimental setups pretty
standard
stuff for computational integer
programming um
looking at two metrics here average time
to the best solution
we get a 33 reduction so it used to take
with default skip
71 minutes to find the best solution it
finds within a run
and we've reduced that to 46 minutes and
if we look at this metric the primal
integral which
which i i said you know we care about as
kind of a aggregate
performance metric for primal
solutions now we reduce that roughly by
half
so you know you can find the the
very good solutions much earlier on than
you typically would
uh with skip and this is very consistent
so on 92 percent of the test
instances the schedule that's learned
from training data
finds uh better primal integral
and i should note here that uh this is a
setting where we trained on small
instances and tested on large so
this kind of simultaneously tests
transfer learning potential
uh which which also works uh quite well
in practice
if we do a qualitative comparison of the
schedule that's being learned
the first bar with the default setting
of the solver
so here each color corresponds to a
different heuristic first thing you'll
notice is the orderings are garbled
meaning the default setting of the
solver is not good for the this
generalized independent set problem
and our method finds a completely
different schedule
and also you'll see that the timings for
the different schedules are very
different
so the solver gives a lot more time but
the ordering is so bad and it wastes so
much time
running on promising heuristics and our
method really capitalizes on that
and last we've also compared with
parameter tuning or algorithm
configuration using smac
smack has the benefit of directly
optimizing the metric you care about
so you can tell it to optimize the
primal integral our method cannot do
that it has to
optimize a surrogate um but smack
actually has quite good performance so
it roughly matches our method
maybe a bit worse but it requires one to
two orders of magnitude
more time so whereas our method can
terminate in a few hours
fully data collection plus training um
smac needs a lot more time because it's
sequential algorithm
and you can only parallelize it by
running multiple copies of the algorithm
and so i'll wrap up with that and we've
tried to propose a
simple framework for managing heuristics
in branch and bound
the nice thing about it is that it
extends to any kind of heuristic it
doesn't assume even
that's a mixed integer linear program
actually skip is a mixed integer
non-linear programming solver so we
could
handle non-linear instances quite easily
and beyond that it's also very fast to
train with massive parallelization
and it can be used very easily at test
time with
zero overhead essentially just by
setting a bunch of
parameters uh and so if you found this
interesting please check out our
preprint on
on on archive and i'm happy to answer
any questions
thank you alias thank you very much for
a fantastic talk and i apologize for
um not being able to join in the first
few minutes
because my zoom gave me a lot of problem
anyway so i'm here
thank you again uh questions please
i have a comment she has a question yes
please go ahead so
this is more of a comment that uh i'm
reminded of i put a link in the chat
there was a world
maybe 15 years ago it was about
scheduling
very similar problem it's the context of
compiler where you have many heuristics
and find again the schedule
i think i think that would be just
useful for you to take a look i think
the machine learning has advanced
significantly since then
they basically if i recall they use a
genetic algorithm to find an optimal
an optimal sequence of heuristics but a
lot of
similarities in the spirit yes no
that's a great point i see the paper it
seems quite relevant there's also
uh the problem that we set up in terms
of scheduling
is actually related to one that comes up
in database
query processing so this kind of thing
where you need to order and there's
different costs to ordering
things in differently uh so this seems
quite in that line
i would say in general this issue of of
finding the right order
of heuristics is probably shows up in
many places
not just in you look at one contact by
suspect as the compilation is one
and i suspected if you dig you'll find
other application areas for your
technique
yeah yeah thanks for that um
actually we are building a string solver
where i think this kind of a scheduling
might be very relevant
uh that you proposed here elias and so
we will
connect with you offline sure discussing
yeah left of that
um but as you well know it is uh there
have been a lot of work in
variable ordering inside solvers right
so we use some kind of a reinforcement
learning based approach multi-arm banded
style methods and i wonder if there is a
room for that kind of an approach here
yeah
so you interact with the environment and
get feedback in an online fashion
yeah that allows you to select the best
schedule yeah that's
implemented uh with skip uh so so there
is a method
by by a stiff developer name of gregor
hendell
which which does essentially a bandit
approach it observes
whether a heuristic is finding solutions
or not and it tries to adjust
dynamically
how how long to give it and its priority
uh but
uh we compare to that as part of our
experiments when we say default skip
that thing is also included uh and it it
i mean it's leveraging less information
than we are because we have seen some
historical training instances
uh that's why i say default skip is by
no means
trivial it's quite engineered it does
quite a few smart things
just maybe not enough to capture
everything uh about
that then suggest something is whether
you can combine an
offline approach and marry that with an
online approach to
to even you know squeeze even more uh
yeah sort of the system yeah and i know
i know this is done in parameter
configuration for example
you can warm start a certain
configuration or parameter selection
methods and then
it's kind of a meta-learning type thing
yeah there are
uh moshe has put some more papers
yes thank you chat any additional
questions
uh i'm sorry no yes go ahead um
you gave us uh the
test case this generalized independence
that
problem and you got this nice result
i wonder if you try to use this approach
to a problem for which you already know
that the
human tune the heuristics that the
the the team uh who implemented
and how they compare i mean maybe on
some problem that they already studied
these compares favorably
so yeah yeah that's a that's a that's a
great uh great point actually in the
paper
i don't didn't have time to show that
but we actually did that
so what we did is as people are experts
working with
skip and on the team we have the skip
developers basically
we went and manually tuned uh
the skip heuristics and we played around
the parameters and ran lots of
experiments and all kinds of stuff like
that
and we got a better version of skip
default
and we compare to that in the paper and
and and that is better than the default
one
but not as good as our method
thank you liz uh in interest of time
let's take more questions offline
and solomo do you want to
[Music]
put your slide up please sure
thank you so while solomon is setting up
allow me to introduce him he's a phd
student at the university of alberta
and he recently came up with an
interesting uh solver called xsat
that builds on top of
lrb and v6 it's a very interesting
idea and he's due to complete his phd
soon this year
so without further ado solomon the
online floor is yours please go ahead
uh can everyone hear me i guess everyone
yeah okay i can hear you you don't see
your screen as far as i can tell
oh okay i have to share my screen